talking about trans issues is one of the
most polarizing conversations you can
have these days and in many cases if not
most cases people seem to barely know
what they're talking about to be clear
for today I'm going to be talking about
transgender people not transformers
while they're both more than meets the
eye I'm not here to talk about Autobots
and Decepticons so let's discuss
transgender people and the entire
whirlwind debate around their very
existence what comes to mind immediately
when you mentioned trans issues is the
North Carolina law that was the outrage
of the month when Republican Governor
Pat McCrory signed House bill to putting
into policy a statewide plan to ban
individuals from using public bathrooms
that did not correspond to their
biological sex immediately the media
went bonkers and McCrory and basically
the whole state of North Carolina were
labeled transphobic bigots which of
course was followed by the usual feeding
frenzy of partisan hackery
the narrative quickly became either you
want creepy adult men to be able to be
in a woman's bathroom with a little girl
or you hate trans people maroon5 demi
lovato Bruce Springsteen and other
entertainers canceled concerts in North
Carolina and the NBA even pulled the
all-star game scheduled in 2017 out of
the state so let's back up here for just
a second first off transgender people
are an absurdly tiny minority within the
country and the world
this doesn't mean they should be ignored
but the virtue signaling coming from
celebrities and pundits was totally
overblown why should all of the people
of North Carolina be punished for the
actions of their governor yeah they
voted him in but should every
politician's decision decide how a whole
state full of individual people is
treated I don't think so how many of the
people who were part of the outrage
machine even know a transgender person
or have volunteered at a LGBT Center or
donated to their cause I'm guessing very
few but showing outrage instead of
actually helping people in a
constructive way is apparently how you
demonstrate how good of a person you are
in 2016 so let's unpack exactly what
happened in North Carolina for just a
second first off trans people have been
using whichever bathroom they see fit in
North Carolina and every other state for
as long as they've existed and as far as
I know there hasn't been a widespread
problem relating to them going into the
bathroom of their choice and if there
has been a problem it probably has been
violence directed at by trans person
themselves not the other way around
so in effect the Republican House and
Senate of North Carolina decided to pass
a law to stop the presumed issue where
there was no ample evidence of a problem
in the first place in short it seemed
more about moralizing about the
existence of transgender people than
passing a law which really needed to be
passed and by the way aren't Republicans
supposed to be for individual liberty
and small government well creating laws
about bathrooms doesn't seem to be in
line with limited government thinking at
any level whatsoever now don't worry I'm
not gonna let the Democrats get off the
hook here either
in response to this misguided law
President Obama issued a federal
directive on how public schools should
deal with transgender kids use of the
bathroom saying that kids should be
allowed to go into whichever bathroom
they see fit I believe Obama's actions
were well-intentioned and the president
was trying to protect this tiny minority
of transgender students but his response
in effect was another power grab by the
federal government actually it could be
argued that this directive by Obama is a
direct violation of the Tenth Amendment
which states that any power not
specifically delegated to the federal
government in the Constitution goes back
to the states ultimately this case in
which Republicans made an issue where no
issue existed allowed a Democratic
president to take power away from the
local state government and put it in
hands of the Fed long story short this
is a perfect just a perfect example of
how dysfunctional our political system
has become I should back up here for
just a second and actually address trans
people instead of making this all about
the government
from the trans people that I know to
everything I've read and heard about
them trans people seem to just want to
live the most authentic life they can
pretty much just like the rest of us
imagine for one moment that you weren't
born into the body corresponding with
the sex that you felt that you were none
of us who aren't going through this
horrific and truly existential e
conflicting experience kind of any clue
what this is like that in and of itself
is enough for me as a liberal to have
compassion for trans people and what to
help them in their struggle for the same
dignity that we all want of course a
libertarian who might not care about
trans people one way or another could
come to the exact same conclusion by
arguing that the government has no right
to dictate which bathroom a person goes
into this like with gay marriage and
legalizing marijuana is another in the
long line of issues where I see a new
political center aligning people who
want to do good by their fellow man
coupled with people who want to rein in
the power of the government are coming
to the same conclusions based on respect
of the individual and that's an
incredibly beautiful thing
I believe this new coalition of people
coming together despite political
differences is exactly what could be the
antidote for our obviously broken
political system my guest this week is
Blaire white a youtube personality who
yes so happens to be trans and she's
also a men's rights activist adding MRA
to the equation really flips the
oppression Olympics on its head and you
guys know I'm all about that I'm looking
forward to having a wide-ranging
conversation with Blair about her own
personal journey the battle for equality
her unique position on men's rights as
someone who is assigned male at birth
but now identifies as a woman and much
more I doubt she'll have all the answers
I certainly know that I won't have all
of them and that's exactly why we have
to have these important conversations
you